okay let's play rosa boss
whose game i aborted earlier because uh
probably because of forgetfulness now
we're back e4 time
what are the odds that we get the exact
same line
not happening
da it's time for gamma time
do i do i refute the saffron
i'm gonna feel bad about it but
um
okay let's punish the stafford
there should be two
i'm gonna play the main main line
c3
wait what is this line though this oh
this is a magical line
ah okay d4 queen h4 is coming
and g3
i feel bad doing this but
okay we're having an instructive stream
ooh queen h3
wait queen
h3 i can just set up for the next game
undeveloping
[Music]
undeveloping my only developed piece
it feels so good
but also kind of bad because i'm hurting
the stafford
somewhere in the world ben feingold is
smiling
always play bishop
f1 can i castle
how well did the programmers program
leach us
because this is kind of an edge case
where
like can you castle and take the queen
[Music]
i guess not
okay
oh poor rasa boss
that's a nice idea i think i've maybe
seen this like at some point
a while ago this bishop f1 idea
during my phase of really digging into
these lines
i guess now we know why like queen h3 is
just not playable
so now we have a case
where yeah white has an extra queen
[Music]
i haven't lost a single pawn
[Music]
let's keep being greedy
so many
early christmas presents
and or belated hanukkah presents
of okay black wants to play this
but i'll keep taking stuff
yeah is the staff or gambit officially
dead
i feel like after this game
it's at least one step closer to dying
can i win i want to win connect 8 along
a diagonal
but i can't legally have pawns on a1 and
h8
so maybe the plan is connect 6
or connect 8 like this
i'm six moves away
and then with another time
might be difficult though
just have to ensure i don't lose any
pawns so the conference would be in
illinois which is no way too far from
you any interest in possibly doing the
human plus engine map absolutely awesome
what was the name of the conference
again the
something about technology if i'm if i'm
in the country
oh no my opponent
oh rasabos is in the chat says wi-fi
went down
but now okay
yeah when you lose internet connection
in in a position like this
it has appearance of rage quitting
which is i think a natural
maybe the wi-fi wanted to rage quit
the wi-fi detected such a
[Music]
such a position
[Music]
and it couldn't support the bandwidth
i was gonna say that um
i am traveling internationally coming up
i mentioned earlier but
yeah maybe singapore backgammon wasn't
around
i'll be going to gibraltar
towards the end of january to play
a serious otb tournament
still have to book my flights
i might do some traveling a little bit
before and after too
yeah we do have the gibraltar command
with more information
[Music]
okay
can i trap the bishop
if the bishop moves back to a6 i can't
trap it
if it moves to c2 it's more trappable
good to see you streaming
[Music]
oh it's good to see you subbing again
rumble rob subbing for three months
okay
let's start the
what do we call it
hey it's uh
[Music]
i don't know what we call it
it's a cocoon of bishops and king and
pawns
oh phalanx or phalanx
my failings of pawns
or an avalanche whoa it's inform hunter
with ten thousand bits
we haven't even reached connect eight
it's only connect five content
cheers
thank you
oh cheers
spasiba
ocean spasiba
also
previet cocktail
[Music]
i really appreciate that thanks so much
that's so kind
i have to get rid of this b-pawn somehow
the problem with having pawns like this
i don't have any open files
i'm really spoiling myself here
okay so my plan is to make an artificial
open vial with my rook
ah this is too much fun
rook was hanging
rook was hanging i could have taken the
rook
i thought i was getting rick rolled but
i should have taken the rook
i'm too distracted by my own pawns
it's like when you grow your hair your
hair out so long
it covers your eyes and you can't see
properly
you need to get a haircut
or i could turn my hair into a mohawk
or a pyramid
oh this would be a nice uh
a nice pyramid scheme
[Music]
whoa it's pie hole thank you
for your time
merry christmas also
quack also happy new year that's really
kind
thanks so much
also thank you
happy new year merry christmas happy
holidays
hello to lexi nay
yay
okay i'm making progress i could have
won this pawn
but that's okay
it's sam to help pay for the car
do i take a road trip to gibraltar
i feel like that would require a ferry
and probably not the tooth fairy
but like an actual large boat
how do i win stuff
it's annoying because uh oh there we go
okay no longer annoying like the bishop
defended the rook which defended the
pawns which
are now
being consumed by my pieces
i'm having too much fun here it's about
to happen
[Music]
move 44 connect 8.
i still feel bad because this came from
a stafford
but what oh let's not hang upon
[Music]
i was about to hang upon
that would have been like really tragic
ah but now i can't play queen g5
that's my one hope
okay pawns are about to go marching
can i win connect eight again
and then another time
and then another time after that
oh it's too much fun
i'll be so upset if the
wait how do i
save my queen
okay let's let's just simplify a little
bit
i sack a rook to
to simplify
here we go
wait my queen's in the way
okay that's my second connect eight
actually my third if we count the
starting position
okay get ready for it
wait how do i checkmate with connect8
wait
this is surprisingly confusing
is it possible
i can't play this because this
i don't think it's possible
wait let's start by
i'm trying to conceptual
oh no
wait i have this move
this is looking risky
it's almost stalemate
but it's not stalemate
ah i see how to do it
oh
it is possible
look at this
check
wow
wow
check me
oh it's so pretty
it's so pretty
okay
that all started from uh
from a funny opening too
it was uh the undeveloping tactic to win
the queen
okay that felt pretty good
youtube thumbnail time
thank you ross the boss for being a good
sport
and for regaining your internet
connection except
maybe
maybe it's still somewhat poor
oh man i just joined what happened here
gonna go cry myself to sleep tonight
bible thump
oh no your tears